yeah so what's been going on with you
man I'm just working man I just dropped
a little like remix mixtape on industry
beats called grip tape because I've been
skating a lot so I used to skateboard a
lot when I was a kid you've been skating
a lot yeah well you why you look so
shocked I'm good bro I didn't know you
were a skater I could skate really good
so you just randomly decided to pick it
back up because I was having a lot of
anxiety you know like at the beginning
of the pandemic like I was like yo I'm a
grown man having like these anxiety
symptoms that I never dealt with before
in my life like so now you just sort of
Escape
them out because skateboarding is like a
really like meditation like activity
right you have to really focus like if
you [ __ ] up your foot placement or
something because you're thinking about
some other [ __ ] you're gonna fall and
like you know bust your ass so you
really have to focus and it allows you
to really disconnect
so the mixtape is you jumping on other
beats that was the one we just dropped
yeah that was uh I got like a bunch of
people on it I got um
like a bunch of like the homies we just
wrapped on a bunch of [ __ ] we wrapped on
like uh kick push just you know because
I've been skating that's natural had to
do it you know then a milli because
that's my name you know but now we're
moving on we're about to drop some real
music
um end of this month end of October so
with the mixtape you obviously can't put
it on dsps so it's on the one website
industrybeets.com I've never even heard
of that what did you just say it was on
we we dropped on industry beats like
they were recorded on top of Beats oh
industry dog I thought that was like a
new platform I'm sorry
I thought you were like yo it's on we
dropped it on industry beats and I'm
like oh that must be like a new depth if
the new dap fifth nah so it's on DatPiff
no we didn't we just put it right
through it on YouTube okay SoundCloud on
YouTube yeah because you should put it
on that pip I know right why not I was
just yeah big shots to [ __ ] that
picture and there's my mixtapes app a
lot of people use that oh [ __ ] look at
you you [ __ ] up my whole life right
now yeah have about to take over my
market shout out to YouTube man